my father has always tried to improve
the education system his whole life and
so he's very Mission driven probably the
reason why I want to do this is because
he's just made me so aware that it's
important to do something that's good
for the world and he will make it really
clear if you're doing something that
doesn't really benefit the world at all
except for your own Pockets basically
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host he Maus and on this week's episode
I was joined by Mel kst he's the
co-founder of Bluebird what's really
unique about your story is you know what
you Market everywhere is you're an exas
professional now recruiting for SAS
businesses you start as an SDR and then
you progress from SDR to customer
success manager account executive
director sales when you join that
business the business was around 6
million annual Cur Revenue by the time
you left it was 250 um million annual
Cur revenue and what I love about m is
he is open to trying different things
going against the norm so in this
conversation we really talk about how
they've gone about that how they've
approached growing their recruitment
business in a
non-traditional way as well as that he
is someone who is really passionate
about building a culture for people to
thrive in so we really go into how Mel
has gone about developing his leadership
skills how he's gone about executing
amazing one-on Ones quartly reviews and
what he's really done to get the best
out of his people professionally and
personally so how how have you gone
about reminding these people why they're
doing what they're doing I there's
there's two things that I hope enjoy
this week's
episode M welcome to the podcast thank
you
sir been looking forward to this
obviously we've got to know each other
over the past couple of months have
enjoyed seeing the the rise of bluebird
from afar found it really interesting
the way that you're going about your
business so
really looking forward to unpacking uh
this journey that uh you've been on so
everyone listening to this can learn
from it and also be inspired from it uh
and take things into their own business
their own career um so before I ask you
the the million pound question just to
give everyone some immediate context on
you know who you are where you're at
where you're going if I miss anything
here that's important please correct me
uh but obviously we we've done some prep
for this so
what's really unique about your story is
you know what you Market everywhere is
you're an ex SAS professional now
recruiting for SAS businesses so um you
know a big chunk of your career was in
the SAS space so some of the you know
key highlights there of working in the
space for 10 years was uh for one of the
businesses that you um worked for for uh
nine uh years was you started as an SDR
and then you progress from SDR to
customer success manager account
executive director sales by the time you
left you was managing 45 people when you
joined that business the business was
around 6 million annual curring revenue
by the time you left it was 250 um
million annual current Revenue so a
really interesting Journey I'm sure you
went on there in terms of a growth
journey and then after that you then
join another business where you joined
as a first uh VP High you built a sales
team from scratch and took it to three
Mill uh 3 million in annual reir revenue
so I'm sure so many learnings uh along
the way and then in
20 20 started a recruitment business
with your co-founder Bluebird um and
then over the last couple of years
obviously you're in your fourth uh year
now first year you ended up uh being
around four of you second year seven uh
seven of you and then third year uh 13
people and then you're continuing uh to
grow uh this year so I think today you
know it's going to be twofold talking
about how you've gone about growing this
business I'm sure there's going to be
some learnings that you've applied to
recruitment that people you know
listening to this can uh take themselves
uh I know you're big into a leadership
mindset so there there'll be a bunch of
things that we cover but let's start
with the the million pound question I'd
love to hear your take on what you
believe uh makes up you know the common
characteristics and traits of a top
performer in in today's market great
thanks for the introduction uh hem and
I'm also looking forward to it so let's
dive right into it I think uh in order
to be an outstanding recruiter in this
market you need to be surprisingly
different and then the next question of
course would be how do you make sure
you're surprisingly different I think
that starts with Integrity I think
Integrity is the number one thing we
look at when we hire people um I always
tell my team to try to give the best
possible advice to candidates and
clients especially when it's not in your
own best interest because that's where
you you'll really make a lasting
impression I think outside of that
there's ton of things we can talk about
like like grid and drive and stuff which
I've heard a lot uh while listening to
your podc
U but if I'd add two uh next to
Integrity it would be authenticity in
order to be able to create a a good
connection really fast which I think is
crucial and curiosity like as a
recruiter you need to be great at asking
questions which I think you're a
superstar at um so I at that one through
the list as
well yeah really
interesting um so let let's just get
straight into this I think what what I'd
love to just hear your take on because
it's something that you Market pretty
heavily you even have it on your
LinkedIn not just a recruitment agency
we are former SAS
professionals right so let let's dive
into that because I also noticed that
you recently announced that you're uh
launching a you know Devon it part of
your business with someone who is a
fullstack developer right so you you
you've really committed to this model
you've really committed to this model of
we take people who have been in the
shoes of the people that we support help
um so we can deliver them which I feel
like you believe uh an even better
recruitment service so talk to us about
your perspective on this why is this so
important to you why have you really
doubled down on we're not just a
recruitment agency we've we're former
sash professionals we're now recruiting
the space why do you feel like that
gives you an upper hand and why have you
really doubled down on that strategy
yeah yeah really good question um so
yeah I believe that people that have
firsthand experience in a role that they
do recruitment for gives huge
advantages like if I'd asked a question
to for example an accountancy firm and I
asked them who they would trust more to
qualify an accountant would that be a
recruiter that graduated few years ago
went to Recruitment and has done
accountancy recruitment for a year or
two or would they have more faith in an
accountant doing the qualification to
see if that accountant's actually good
enough for the role my guess would be
that the fast majority majority of
people would have more trust in an
accountant doing that qualification
that's basically what we're replicating
in the software space um so I think if
you what every recruitment company
preaches is that they introduce the best
people fast right like that's the task
of any recruitment agency it's pretty
hard to like be different from other
agencies because everyone is saying that
they deliver the best people fast that's
when I say that to a prospect everybody
says the same they say yeah everybody
says that so then the question is how do
you actually do that um and I think I
think when it comes to getting in touch
with the very best people in the
market they are very much more inclined
to respond to you to your messaging to
your creative Outreach obviously there's
things you can do in that Outreach to
increase the chance of being responded
to but simply coming from the industry
leads to responses that are
significantly different different from
what a recruiter without that background
gets like I get multiple uh messages
every single day of people responding
like hey it's so awesome that you're
from the industry I typically never
speak to recruiters but like love to
hear a bit about your journey and let's
have a chat and then I've built that
relationship so when there're then
looking for a new opportunity I'm
already I already have one foot in the
door um so that allows us to really get
in touch with people that other
recruiters typically typically don't
speak with and then the second part is
you also need qualify them to see if
they're actually good enough I strongly
believe that if you do not like if you
do not have a background within um that
that specific role it's really hard to
do that qualification first of all and
it's a big question whether the person
you're speaking with will allow you to
qualify them especially if they're High
Caliber like if I'm when I spoke to a
recruiter when I was still a sales
director if I'd be sitting down with a
recruiter I I would want to know which
opportunities they have like that's the
first thing on my mind if they're done
then going to try to assess my
background I'm like hey that's not why
I'm here like I'd like to understand
which opportunities you have um but
we're talking from peer to peer so they
really allow us also to do that
qualification um which means I feel like
having that firsthand experience allows
us to do what you need to do as a
recruiter which is get in touch with the
best people qualify them to see to see
if they're actually the right fit and
then make the introduction and I guess
an extra part is great companies also
recognize that value proposition
and therefore we also succeed at signing
up really good clients so I think it's a
pretty big USB and that's also why we
Market it
strongly it's yeah I'm I'm it's
interesting right because I feel like I
I like for me what what I feel like I'm
hearing there is because of because you
have that industry experience and your
team
do you get something that a lot of
recruiters have to to work hard for
which uh you get something that yeah a
lot more quickly compared to what
recruiters have to work really hard for
which is
trust because like for me I feel like
the best recruiters do commit to really
understanding their industry have they
ever walked in the shoes of a VP of
sales no but have they spoken to over
100 150 200 VP of sales to really grasp
and understand what it is that they do
understand what good looks like I think
I think you know the best recruiters are
good at that so I like I definitely uh
believe that you know good quality
qualification can come with training um
and experience because the great thing
about recruitment is like if I'm
speaking to M the VP of sales at one
business how many other VP of sales do
you know you might know 10 20 but as a
recruiter if you're only networking with
you know those people uh you might speak
to 10 20 a week so there's so much
knowledge uh and information Insight
that recruiters get access to if harness
correctly um you can do a really great
job so like for me that that's what I
feel like I'm hearing is a trust piece
personally yeah and I agree with what
you're saying right like I'm absolutely
not saying that if you do not have that
background that there's no way you can
do a good job you've personally
connected me with a few people in the
industry that I was very impressed by so
U not saying it's the only way to do a
good job but it definitely is a huge
Advantage yeah yeah no I I get that and
so you said there as well like you said
what like why you've also lent into that
is it is it is different it does enable
you to stand out and it's actually you
know a proposition that resonates with
your ideal clients yeah yeah no I'm I'm
not surprised I mean you know the world
that we're in selling a training product
where it's actual recruiters delivering
the training it's what people buy into
right it's people like like I said I
feel like it's that that trust piece uh
and you know recruiters consistently
trying to build that trust and and build
their reputation so yeah I I wanted to
start there and get your perspectives on
that because I think that will give
people a bit of an in insight into what
you're about the way that you think and
I think because of this as well you've
gone about approaching your recruitment
business in maybe in a non-typical way
right you haven't got the recruiter
Playbook of working for a recruitment
Agency for 5 years you become a director
or you was a top performer you're like
right I'm going to do this on my own I'm
going to start own business and then you
bring all the best bits that you
perceive are the best bits into your
business and then you build on that
right so let me just paint a picture for
everyone in terms of like the team like
some of the key things around the team
setup what you're doing now and then we
can dive into the actual business stuff
and the things that you've you know
learned uh that you're you're doing so
again feel free to correct me if I'm
wrong here but uh obviously from a up
until August last year you was a big
contributor to revenue right like you
you was very you was quite responsible
for a large chunk of the client
opportunities that came in um and you
was generating um you know a good chunk
of the revenue for the business is that
fair yeah absolutely about 25% of the
revenue 25% yeah cool so that that's
quarter right so that's a a good amount
so then from August last year you've
been on this journey of obviously you're
still I think you said to me you're
still going to um Bill x amount this
year uh but like your focus has been
more the following one-on-one coaching
marketing optimizing CRM processes
you're trying to spend a lot more time
on the business 25% of it is still you
know driving client pipeline job
opportunity pipeline uh and yeah a large
chunk of it is leadership and one And1
coaching as well is that fair absolutely
and then you've got your co-founder
who's more I put like operations you
know runs meeting uh runs meeting every
Monday morning organized company trips
salary paying commission organizing I
put you put organ organizing quote
unquote the that all the stuff that
maybe you might find difficult to keep
on top of biwe training sessions like
yeah a great combination yeah so let's
sort of go into some of this because I
think what I found really interesting in
putting some of uh the some of these um
insights together
was you you put here the um so I corre
from here I don't know how like up to
date this is but you shared with me how
like a like 90% of the customers are
signed up through the founders
yeah that's still fairly accurate still
yeah so 90% of the customers have signed
up for so what does that mean like the
they're coming inbound to you are you
proactively generating these
opportunities to work with companies
like what what like what does that mean
firstly how does that happen 90% because
that's so many Founders listeners would
love to be in that position yeah
so I'll have to take a step back from
the start because if I only talk about
the way Business Development looks like
right now it's an unrealistic image and
it seems like everything yeah um when we
started the business so both me and my
business partner have like huge
experience doing business development
right we've done it for years i'
literally there hasn't been a year where
I haven't been doing it um so the muscle
is there so when we started the business
we we did highly creative Outreach to um
all the prospects that we wanted to work
with I'll give you one example we uh we
prospected out to a company that was
called watermelon uh and I actually went
to a grocery store bought a watermelon
and sent a highly personalized video
where I started the video with the
watermelon in in front of my face and
then started doing my introduction while
slowly lowering the watermelon without
laughing uh like that's how far we went
in order to get in touch with company so
it wasn't automated Outreach it was
highly personalized video Outreach to
every single uh company in uh that was
within our ICP uh and we built an email
sequence that had a response rate of
about 35 to 40% so extremely high it was
also a video was still coming up like
now a lot of people are doing it so it
converts a bit less um but it started
with me and my business part partner
putting in a tremendous amount of work
in order to start signing our first
clients and then when we started signing
our first clients our number one
priority was making sure we executed on
that extremely well um and that led to
referrals so I think referrals is a big
part of um the clients that we get today
and that comes from Simply delivering
towards the clients that we work with
and also delivering quite a unique
experience to the candidates that we
work with simultaneously throughout that
whole process we've from the moment we
started I throughout my SAS career I
already realized the power that Venture
Capital firms and private Equity firms
have
so like in month two uh of the F when we
started our business I reached out to
one of the top fec's in the software
space um set up a meeting with their ta
specialist who was happy to speak
because we came from the industry and
she liked the value proposition even
though we had proven nothing yet and
then kept in contact with her every
single month updating her about like the
progress of her company placements that
we done clients that we signed and then
after eight months they finally gave us
an opportunity to uh work with one of
their clients we placed 18 account
Executives within two months in Germany
which like anyone working in the SAS
industry doing sales roles 18 AES in
Germany within two months is an
extraordinary feed um and and and just
simply by delivering we've built those
relationships also with those FCS as
soon as we got the chance uh and and
because of that we continuously get new
opportunities so uh referrals is a
really big part Partnerships is a really
big part which I uh I I consider FCS and
pees also Partnerships but also for
example we work with sales advisers that
work with software companies that advise
us get a little bit of a kickback fee
um and then we still do Outreach
ourselves continuously it's not like you
know eight or 16 hours per week it might
be you know one or two hours every week
uh and we also sign up some clients
through that but the fast majority is is
through Partnerships Venture Capital
firms um and referrals no I appreciate
you going back there because I know we
were jumping ahead so I appreciate you
breaking that down because I know that
yeah because if you would if like that
stat then make yeah it's important to go
back basically and understand you know
the key things that have helped you get
to that so I appreciate you're doing
that I guess would you mind you broke it
down quite quite well there to be fair
but I think this is where people could
maybe like I I found I found that
there's a lot of people now or more and
more people are starting to learn and
take things from the SAS sales space
into the recruitment world or like more
and more people are at anyway I find so
it'd be interesting just to hear like
what in that in that first year on the
goto Market strategy like what were the
like what were the like core parts of
that plan that you deemed to be really
important like how did you actually
approach that you mentioned the word ICP
um but you mentioned High highly
personalized Outreach you mentioned you
know your experience of knowing how
important VC relationships are so you
mentioned quite a few things there cuz
what's really interesting there is it
sounds like you've in a really smart way
built an
ecosystem that yeah can be a bit of a
referral engine really um off the back
of you doing an exceptional job right
and building that credibility but if we
were to just uh focus in on you know how
you and your business partner did f um
what did the go-to market strategy look
like that first year what were like the
fundamental parts of that plan that I'm
sure you took from your SAS sales career
and then applied to building this
recruitment business what were some of
the the core parts of that yeah I have a
hard time not laughing a little bit
because I don't consider myself a big
strategist at all oh really yeah um I
think I'm operationally good but I'm not
a huge strategist so when we set up the
business just to give an example why I
was laughing um our first candidate
interviews we did face to face hourong
with me and my business partner like
complete
inefficient and um so I
think I don't think there was a really
clear strategy like if you if you look
at what our strategy was the strategy
was making sure we delivered an
exceptional service that was the
strategy and and I also really like to
keep things simple and I think it's
still the biggest reason for our success
is the fact that we just deliver a
really good service I for anyone who's
listening um who hasn't read the
Challenger sale like I highly recommend
listening to the reading the Challenger
sale which in the Challenger sale they
also basically say in order to build a
good relationship it's not necessarily
knowing about someone's dog or their
wife it's about delivering Great Value
to their business that's how you truly
build a relationship and then the other
things are not even that important I
think we could do more of the
traditional relationship building
meeting people face to face and getting
to know a bit about their personal life
but companies in and stick with us
because we deliver really good value to
their business so I think that was like
if if anything that was the strategy
other than that I there wasn't a
long-term plan uh business plan that we
created or something we just dive right
into
it
how how often do you and your team use
your track record to partner with
clients can you repeat that
question how cuz you spoke about it a
lot like what I found is a lot of
recruiters don't use their track
record like like so it'd be interesting
to hear your take on like you worked
really hard to get these results behind
you and ultimately build up evidence to
back up not only are you excess
professionals you're also great
recruiters that can deliver an
exceptional
service you said you was kep you kept
highlighting to that uh um you know the
the VC like hey we achieved this this
month we had this har project we did
this so just curious to hear your take
on how often do you and your team
utilize this track record and your
results in the sales process when
speaking to clients when closing clients
how often do you do that yeah that's a
really good question and a very um
current question for us because now
we've built this huge track track record
we have some really impressive results
we don't really Market it at all like we
have these face to-face conversations
with clients where we explain what we've
done
uh but we don't properly keep keep track
of you know what we've achieved in the
past so I've now hired um an office
manager my sister actually and she's
she's pretty good at marketing she's
documenting all of these things now
building case studies and everything and
making sure we're revamping the whole
website building an entirely new website
we've started working with a new
marketing agency so um if you ask me how
we have been doing it I don't think we
have been doing it in a structured way
uh if I look at the future we're looking
to do that in a very structured way
making sure we communicate uh all our
achievements really clearly with the
companies that we work with yeah that's
definitely a missed opportunity for
sure sure you've been doing great by now
but having visual assets and supporting
assets to back up these track records
case studies hiring projects that's
that's an absolutely no brain up I think
this also has to do with the phases that
you go through as a company right like
um when I was and also the importance of
moving from founder Le sales to at some
point having your team do the
recruitment piece and creating more
availability for yourself because now
with this new website that we're
building with this new marketing agency
that we're working with I literally have
to spend days to speak with him about
the core messaging ICP uh which channels
we're going to use create video content
create written content and and creating
really good copy is not something you
can just easily you know this more than
anyone else probably creating good copy
is really difficult um so it requires a
lot of time I simply would not have been
able to do that at a you know a high
level a year ago um but now I really do
have the time so that's why we're uh
starting with that
now so let's get into some of these
other things I think you've done in an
interesting way so we mentioned that 9%
of customer sign up fre Founders so like
what we've leared there is at the
beginning you really double down on
doing the Reps getting your name out
there getting in front of people but
most importantly absolutely commit to
delivering a world class service
achieving results and then continuing to
build on that and that's you know built
a bit of a referral engine but you've
also been smart with the network that
you build whether that be you know
Partnerships like you said like Sal SAS
sales advisors or advisers that operate
in your space the VC community and then
you're going to have clients that are
going to recommend you if you do a great
job so super interesting I think what I
then found was again correct me for this
is wrong but you said yeah so 90% of
customers sign up for fre Founders and
then it's up for grabs in terms of
anyone placing with these clients and I
think you said so whoever places with
this client that might come through the
channels of you or your co-founder they
would get 75% of that and then 25% of it
would go towards the founders so your
team don't have targets
no so let let's just talk about that why
do your why do your team like talk to us
about your philosophy here like why do
your team not have
targets yeah that's a good question um
why don't why doesn't my team
have no the reason we did that is like
if I look at myself I I was never overly
motivated by targets I I definitely
wanted to be top of the board that was
really important to me but targets less
so um and I think targets can also lead
to complacency if you're working with
people that are very intrinsically
motivated and have clear personal goals
like if someone has a personal goal of
being Financial free at a certain age I
don't have to give them a Target because
they're just looking at that personal
goal calculating back exactly what they
need to do and then trying to achieve
that goal I love speaking with people
you know I really enjoy training and
coaching I really love having
conversations with people like what are
you working towards if they don't know
what they're working towards okay let's
create what you're working towards and
then let's see what you need to do in
order to get
there if they have that personal goal
that's way stronger than me giving them
targets and
um that's the reason we're not doing it
I wouldn't necessarily recommend it to
every company it works for our
organization because we hire um people
that have quite a bit of experience and
M maturity uh and I only hire people
that are highly intrinsically motivated
so therefore it's not really a
requirement for
us
how just on this like I'm sure everyone
every leader leading uh listening to
this can relate to of of course they may
have commercial targets that they're
aiming for but then what's really going
to drive them and um you know have them
perform more consistently is that person
really understanding why they're doing
what they're doing and that intrinsic
motivation uh intrinsic goals like
how how do you get good at like continue
to reinforce that CU there's one thing
uncovering in an interview process that
what's really important for that person
is buying a home for their family or you
know putting their children through
private school whatever it may be but
then you know to remind them of that
daily weekly
monthly I feel like is can be quite
difficult sometimes like saying hey this
is your target this month like where at
is way more easier right so I'm just
curious how have you how do you then
bake in on a daily weekly monthly basis
quarterly
basis these intrinsic motivations cuz
that that's the only way it works I feel
like is you you find want to hire the
right people that are intrinsically
motivated but then you have to like we
all have to remind ourselves of these
things cuz you know day-to-day gets in
the way so how how have you gone about
reminding these people why they're doing
what they're
doing
curious and that is difficult right like
you know I I'd be lying if I would say
you know someone's not performing i' say
hey remember your life goal and that
they then you know everything's going
well yeah no that doesn't really work
that way unfortunately um but but to
your to your so so everybody goes
through difficulties and periods where
it's not going as well as they would
hope it goes and you know of course that
requires different types of approaches
to get people back to where they need to
be um but as as as we've discussed like
I have a pretty rigorous gadance with um
my team which exists out of weekly
101s and it ex and those weekly 101s are
you know really focused on improving
their skill sets what like one
measurable and one intangible um and I
do quarterly Reflections where which
actually also now part of your uh
training program which I recommend
everyone to use um where I share my
quarterly Reflections document where we
ask questions like you know have you
felt Fearless this quarter are you happy
what would you change about the culture
uh what improvements have you made to
your beliefs and thinking stuff like
that which is pretty abstract type of
questions but those chly Reflections are
the ideal moment to reflect back and say
Hey you know when you joined the
business this was what you're working
towards how's that going like where
where do you feel you are as opposed to
where you thought you would be at this
point um so those are probably the
moments where we can refer to back and
take some time to reflect on it
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vin Cherry the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20,000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning oneup
sales the sales and motivation platform
that enables you to maximize the
potential of your teams we love
partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to his podcast and get up to 10% of the
usage price forever use a link in the
show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode and then
just interested to get your take cuz I
know this is something that you're
really passionate about building a
business a culture that people love
being part of love working for I know
that's something that's really important
to you and and this is a big part of it
right truly committing to trying
understand what is important to your
people at a human being level right so
if I'm listening to this right now and
the only thing I'm talking about with my
people with my team is the tangibles you
haven't got as many CVS out this week
you didn't hit your target last month
this is your target this quarterly like
just the tangibles the things that you
just spoken about in terms of the
intangible you said you use the word
quite abstract that might feel really
far away from like where I'm currently
at what would you say is a good step in
the right direction to start introducing
opportunities to to really try and
understand more about your people or
understanding what drives them or
reminding them what drives them
personally like what what is a good
first step if I'm just talking about the
tangibles how would you start trying to
bake in the other elements which are as
important yeah I'm going to take a step
back again because I also have to touch
upon the measurables and and the
tangibles that you mentioned
because in my opin the way you're
describing it I call that
micromanagement
and um there is a time and a place for
micromanagement and that's when someone
needs it and you need to dive into the
nitty-gritty to see where something is
going wrong uh because someone's not
achieving their numbers um but when I
think of tangibles it's working with
someone who's consistently struggling to
do a certain amount of introductions to
clients like that is a very tangible one
maybe they're doing eight every week uh
and we could try to get it to 11 I'd say
that's something tangible to work
towards um that's a constructive way to
work with someone in your team to see
okay how can we improve those numbers
like you know where where are you doing
something differently from the team that
you're not succeeding at that and like
how do we make sure you get better at it
that's a very positive reinforcement
constructive type of um coaching for a
measurable outcome um when I'm talking
about intangibles which these are
difficult to find and again this is why
we use those sarly Reflections in order
to
like get get those out of the people
that we work with people also need to
feel really safe within the company that
they work at in order to be able to
share those types of things I'll give
you an example like um one of my
colleagues um she approached she felt
more strongly about the negative things
that happened at work which every
recruiter listening to this podcast
there's way more negative stuff happen
happening in this work than positive
stuff like you know it from the 100
introductions that you do maybe three
four or five eventually become
placements um so if you focus on the
negative you're going to have a tough
time which I think you know there's
something to say for hiring a bit more
optimistic people so they will at least
enjoy the job and uh
um but she wouldn't easily share that if
she didn't feel safe to share that with
me um and and because she she shared
that we had like discussions at length
about how that impacted her so she would
really understand uh you know what is
the impact and and and then ask the
question if you would think that the
future would have a positive outcome how
would you how would you feel then and
you know that immediately changed the
way she felt about it I recommended a
couple of books for her to read and and
this is not something you can easily
change over the course of uh a couple of
weeks or a couple of months or maybe
even a couple of quarters sometimes even
a few
years but that's where you can truly
impact someone's life if you're able to
help them see something from a different
perspective and help these deeply
ingrained beliefs and behaviors uh to
change towards the positive uh and that
is what I personally love most about my
work like coaching people and have that
type of impact which goes Way Beyond
just doing a good
job yeah I know that's uh really like
something you're really passionate about
why don't we why don't we also then
segue into because I think this this
would also be good to get your
perspective we're speaking
about Mo like how to get the most out of
your people understanding how you can
motivate them U maybe against the
typical way of like you said
micromanagement or just having their
targets really committing to trying to
create a safe environment so you can
truly understand who they are as people
so you can yeah hopefully create an
environment for them to create what uh
to achieve what they want to personally
not just
professionally but I was just looking at
some of your recent posts and I think
something that might be interested to
talk about here then is how we can also
use this methodology
approach or how you believe you've used
this approach to keep your best people
from
quitting and you shared a few things
right in terms of talking about your
perspective on how you've gone about uh
yeah hopefully positively impacting the
attrition of your staff so why don't we
also just talk about it because I just
build on some of the this perspective of
how you've also then um approach like
keeping your your best people which
again is something that recruitment
agencies often find hard to do talk to
us a bit about your approach there yeah
I
think whether it comes to choosing a
company to work for or staying with that
company I think most people make that
decision based on three criteria which
which is personal
development culture and money I think
those are the three that are typically
most
important we can talk about those at
length but we've just touched upon
personal development right like every
quarter taking a measurable and an
intangible skill to improve on uh which
means at the end of the year you can
just literally see like hey you know
these four measurable ones you've gotten
better at and you know these four core
characteristics we worked on and do you
feel like that improved yeah okay you
became a better person this year like
just imagine if you do this for a few
years you get that excitement around
coaching um so we've talked about
personal
development um when it comes to culture
this this is a bit of a broader topic I
feel because with my last employer I had
a really bad experience with my sales
leader so my core motivation to setting
up a recruitment company
was
predominantly to build bu a culture
where there's certain values that the
company really stands behind um think of
things like um Integrity honesty
transparency I think those are some of
the key ones and rewarding people the
way they should be rewarded not how much
you how little you can reward them and
kind of get away with it um so
everything in our organization is also
built around that which means I don't
want people to feel that it that it is
work of course it's work like I'm not
going to be ideologist of course it's
work in the end however we do make it as
fun as possible and realistically I
think people that really like board
games or like gaming are typically
pretty good for recruitment because it
is also a bit of a game right it's it's
with lives at stake so it's it's an
important game and you have to take it
very seriously but you know you have
your pipeline and some go to you place
one and you celebrate a deal and you can
kind of you have a lot of moments where
you can win um so um so so completely
lost my train of thought so you're
talking about C cult you said how you
how you impact people stay in is
post-development culture and money
you're talking about culture yeah
exactly so um yeah so with the culture
piece like the work itself is quite fun
if you we we put a lot around that like
for example if you hit a and these are
targets right like again I can be an
ideologist and call it goals or
something but these are kind of targets
like if you hit a certain Revenue number
we go out for lunch Friday afternoon at
like beautiful michelan star place these
are things I think most recruitment
agencies do um if they hit a certain
number we give them a week and Away to a
five star hotel um together with our
partner and and if we hit a certain
number every six months we go to a
luxurious destination for a week uh stay
in a beautiful uh place and uh and you
know work but also have fun and further
build that culture so we invest a lot uh
in that culture piece and um yeah and
that really comes from the fact that I
had a bad experience at my previous
employer and wanted to do that
completely different so profit uh with
the potential of exiting the business at
some point is not a driving force within
our company uh growth like when it comes
to headcount is also not a driving force
uh in our company we only higher if it
doesn't impact the chances of the people
within the company to be successful for
example if there's too little
opportunities where simply not hiring or
when the person that we hire is not an
addition to the culture and and because
we're doing all of that we keep the
culture really really strong within the
company and we only hire people that are
really really fit that so that's the
culture piece and then the money piece
this is where we're just lucky in
recruitment if you do a tremendous job
you can earn in my opinion a ridiculous
amount of
money if you if you check mark those
three things um I think it's really hard
for people to leave like you know they
have a great culture they have fun with
their colleagues they're learning
they're growing and they're earning
really well why would they
leave now thanks for breaking that down
I guess why don't we talk about cuz
you've been on you know a bit of a
journey from last August on you know I
guess become less and less like reliant
on right as like a business to to
generate the business relying on you to
to generate 25% of of its
revenues what what do that Journey looks
like like a lot of people listening to
this would have started their business
it's founder Le sales it's you know
they'll like often times it's what
Founders really enjoy particularly if
they come from recruitment background um
so what does that look like for you how
have you how have you gone
about becoming less and less reliant on
from a revenue standpoint what did those
first 3 six nine months look like uh
when maybe you've still you still have
clients saying Hey I want to do
with
you yeah I didn't get that too much to
be honest I don't know what that means
but uh but like 99% of our clients were
like we have a team that delivers really
well I don't think there's a huge
quality difference whether they work
with me or whether they work with one of
the team so I don't think that's
necessarily an issue maybe for Like
Chief Revenue officer or FP level roles
they prefer to work with someone who's
actually you know kind of had seniority
in their uh in their role before but we
also have people that have that type of
seniority MH
um it first of all it's difficult like
because if I'm going to tell a story
here like hey I stopped doing the
recruitment piece and uh you know that
me that meant 25% of the revenue became
available for the team and they did that
and everyone was more successful from
the start it's not true like we we lost
Revenue in first instance like our
Revenue this year is going to be fairly
similar to the revenue that we did last
year despite the fact that we're with a
bigger team and that is because U my
Revenue dropped the only thing is that's
not really an issue because well first
of all I I don't I don't really care
about the fact that there's immediately
like Revenue growth but what it shows is
that the part that I dropped the team
actually picked up not straight away
because I stopped last year uh in August
and uh Revenue definitely dropped the
month after but this year we I can now
see that because I have more time to uh
coach people train people because I have
more time to strategically think about
what Partners to work with we got better
clients because I've been spending more
time on marketing we've seen an increase
in inbound leads um but all of that
stuff takes time it's not from one day
to the other so so I think the moment
you step out of that recruitment piece
which I think in order to be able to
take the leap maybe from like 10 12 13
people to 17 18 20 you will have to do
it
so either you remain at that level or
you step out of it and you take uh take
the leap you're always going to take a
hit and the worst part there is like our
profitability probably got slashed in
half right because the revenue you bring
in yourself is highly profitable however
the revenue that your team members bring
in I think anyway we pay big commissions
so uh the profitability on the deals
that are team members close
significantly lower so when you stop
doing the recruitment work yourself
profitability wise should take a huge
hit um and I'm fine with that but you do
know okay like now we're doing this
profitability with 10 people and we're
going to have to grow to 20 people to
get the same profitability that feels
really weird but I think also from a
personal development perspective I'd
rather do that than continuously do the
recruitment piece myself despite the
fact that I really like the work um I
feel like I'll grow as a person and also
from a retention perspective we need to
grow to give the best people the
opportunity to grow into leadership
roles yeah now that that's that's a
really interesting share so what what
have
been is is there any
like I guess what what I think would be
interesting for people is is there
anything in there that has been like the
the biggest challenge or the the most
common stumbling block out of
interest just in general
making as you continue to like you said
get to 20 like you've broken it down
really well in terms of You' got to face
the facts that you are going to be less
profitable you might think what's like
what am I doing here like you could like
like you said right but like what what
do you what what do you have top of Mind
of being laser focused on to like
continue to overcome or make sure you do
a really good job of so I guess yeah
it's less of a bumpy road yeah yeah that
that is a really good question and I
think I have an interesting question for
it that people that went through this
transition will really recognize
when you're doing
recruitment like it is it's crazy work
right like you're you're doing so many
things at the same time you're getting
LinkedIn messages you're getting text
messages WhatsApp messages emails like
it's super overwhelming and you need to
do a million things at the same time the
moment when you step out of that
recruitment piece it also gives you a
lot of dopamine so you're consistently
like wired and just working working away
um but the moment you step out of it
you're going to have a day where you're
used to days where where where it's
actionpack you have meetings the entire
day and all of a sudden you're going to
have days where you have four or five
hours of nothing like I've I've had
moments in the beginning that I was
sitting there and thinking yeah okay but
like what do I do now do I I maybe maybe
I should set up a search in LinkedIn
because I I don't know like I don't know
what to do with my time right now I'm
lucky because U my father is a
leadership coach like he's he's been my
biggest Mentor throughout my entire life
uh and and and I do have to say when I
made this transition I already went
through that learning phase because I
went through it before in my career when
I transitioned from sales rep to sales
director but I called my dad and I asked
him like yeah I I don't know what to do
like I'm just sitting here I don't have
meetings in my calendar What's Next and
H and my dad said don't do anything for
a little bit just
sit I was say uh okay and they said yeah
just do it and okay so I I did it
without really ask asking any further
questions and I was sitting and my brain
started working it was like oh okay we
could improve this like we should this
process is a bit broken and this I got
this feedback from a client that we
could have done a better job there and
okay I'm going to that's something I and
you know the idea has come to you uh as
the moment you do nothing the ideas come
to you typically my best ideas for the
company come when I'm on holiday uh it's
not when I'm like in the middle of all
the mess um so I think that's probably
the biggest learning being being
comfortable and patient enough for good
ideas to come with you even you know
when you don't have meetings in your
calendar or especially when you don't
have meetings in your calendar and
getting comfortable with that
uncomfortable
feeling
interesting is that that is interesting
I spoke to someone the other day who
spoke about this exact thing and I might
like par like paraphrase this really
wrong but he spoke about he spoke about
it being like when you're in the
trenches doing the doing like maybe when
you was more in uh like August and um
last August and before that it's more
like bottom up leadership you're in the
trenches with these people you're doing
these things and
then the what you're talking about there
is more he he would described as like
topl line leadership so actually your
job is to think about the business how
it can be improved and whatever else
comes with that that's that's what you
need that space for yeah I think
Franklin kovi calls it working on the
business instead of in the
business yeah we've all heard that but I
don't think people visualize that being
sitting with your
thoughts no not I definitely
didn't yeah so it's it's interesting
right so talking about the future then
what is it that you and your co-founder
are really remaining laser focused on
and doubling down
on that you feel is going to continue
helping you get in the right direction
over the next 6 12 18 months with with
this recruitment business You're
Building what are you really doubling
down on you've obviously now got this
new division which I'm sure you've
thought about thought was going to add
another really great pillar to your
business like what is it that you're
really doubling down on yeah to answer
this specific questions what we're
doubling down on is marketing which I
have to say so far has been a Perpetual
disappointment and it led to zero
results almost um it sounds like it's
weird to double down it because two
times nothing is still nothing however
so disappointing um we haven't
successfully gotten high high quality
inbound leads um we've spent a lot of
money without just barely seeing any
result Bas either on the candidate or
the client side um you know when we do
lead
attribution people always knock on our
door because they hurt from us from
someone else not because of there's many
referrals rather than like I saw this
video or content or I downloaded this
yeah and we we just invested quite
heavily like we're talking you know
we're with 13 people we're about to do a
sixf figure investment into marketing
maybe some people listening think yeah
you've already should have done that I
don't know but I feel quite
uncomfortable with such a large
purchase sorry doubt it okay yeah so
we're doing a sixf figure investment in
that and like building an entirely new
website which is also expensive so we're
talking like not a low sixf figure
investment but a decent one
um with a company like I spend a lot of
time speaking with different marketing
agencies together with uh my sister or
office manager to you know qualify all
these different marketing agencies and
find out exactly what we need that feels
like like it really feels like a waste
of time because you're speaking with a
lot of agencies that are all saying the
same thing until we met one from which
we thought hey we think this is really
good what does the same thing sound like
um yeah like uh you know we do sea and
we do SEO and we do LinkedIn campaigns
and uh yeah like you know you have to
pay this and then yeah you're going to
get an outcome but you never really know
what you're going to get because yeah it
is marketing uh that's what I've heard a
million times um and and this marketing
company that we spoke with first of all
did a real analysis got access to all of
our channels did a real analysis of what
we were doing right and what we were
doing wrong the first one that truly
spent time on understanding what our
structure look like uh and and then um
they're doing marketing for their own
company in a really good way that aligns
very well with who we are like they use
a lot of video a lot of thought
leadership um and and and their inbound
leads numbers and and statistics are
very much what we would like um that was
really convincing so we're starting that
partnership I have High Hopes however
like I don't know how it's going to work
out so ask me again in a year what are
you so I'll I'll send it I'll send it to
you after but uh I watched something
recently um which and they spoke about
how to utilize agencies and it was a
really interesting uh perspective where
this guy was talking about like being
really upfront with agencies and saying
hey happy to you know pay you for this
work with you with this but just so you
know like the objective is for us to
really learn from you on how you're
doing this so then we can uh start then
doing it for
ourselves and then hopefully then we can
get to the point where we're doing it
ourselves and we work with you more on a
consultancy basis and then when we're
not getting the value there then you
know we can part ways and it's been a
great relationship like what what is it
that you're really how are you really
hoping this is going to impact your
business so I there's there's two things
that I hope I think that's a really
smart approach by the way I I'll send
you Alex hos is like the I think has the
best business content I'll send you the
video nice appreciate it um like
coincidentally I thought about that
yesterday I was like you know if they do
a tremendous job we should just copy it
and like hire good people yeah so the
way what he says what he says is um I
like butcher it but basically is like be
really up front and say like hey like
really excited for his partnership we'll
work together etc etc but I want to know
I want to work with you and we want to
know exactly how you're doing what
you're doing with us yeah it's smart
it's super smart really smart really
smart so so I was hoping two things and
due to the way I was educated by them
I'm now hoping three things but the the
two things that I was hoping was one of
them just just capturing uh demand
that's out there like companies looking
for a recruitment Agy should should at
least find us uh that that was one and
then the second one was simply awareness
like that people know that we exist
because there's there there are people
that see what we do and are like wow
that makes a lot of sense like I I have
to speak to these people because we come
from the industry and they really like
that value proposition they want to work
with us there's a third one and that is
uh because of them I'm hoping for that
now which is really building that
marketing funnel which I don't have a
good amount of experience with but like
creating awareness sharing more
educational content doing your own
LinkedIn post and that being a funnel
that at some point leads to uh a company
becoming interested and I do believe in
that because the moment I spoke with or
I checked out the website of this
marketing agency once I saw them
everywhere on YouTube on LinkedIn
whatever I opened I saw them uh that was
pretty convincing because that's what I
want to like I want people to be
confronted with our company all the time
if they've shown a little bit of
interest uh so they they're basically
practicing what they preach and if if
that does go to plan you execute it are
you then going to feel even more
confident with the platform you can
provide your team because you know as
well as all the referrals all these
things you've then got this working
funnel where then you can you know
really support your team and having good
quality it leads to cool and
everything's down yeah is that what
you're hoping it will yeah it would be
great if that's scalable like it so so
the reason I'm interested in it it's
just an engine that isn't running like I
I look at our company as a boat with a
couple of engines behind it uh and and
an engine is uh working with FCS and
pees an engine is doing cold Outreach
but an engine is also marketing and that
marketing engine is not running right
now um and I do feel that the potential
is there so that's why we're doubling
down on it despite the fact that we
haven't seen result there um yeah yeah
yeah interested we we'll have to get
your perspective on how it goes because
I think people feel really mixed about
uh these things but I I'll make sure I
send you that video
so becoming 40 years old becoming a
psychologist do you want to help younger
people with depression mental health
challenges you given yourself a number
5.7
million
so you can do this talk to us about this
why why did you when you're 40 years old
want to commit to supporting young
people with with
this yeah I think um
since my father has always tried to
improve the education system his whole
life in whatever capacity he always
tried to improve education in the
Netherlands and so he's very Mission
driven and and probably the reason why I
want to do this is because he's just
made me so aware that it's important to
do something that's good for the world
and he will make it really clear if
you're doing something that doesn't
really benefit the world at all except
for your own Pockets basically um so
that's probably part of it but um I
really like training and coaching people
and helping them and as already
discussed throughout this podcast uh
especially when I can help them with
things that really impact their life and
I I feel like there's lots of people
between their 20s and 30s that go
through depression if they get a little
bit of guidance it can go into the right
direction if they don't get the right
guidance it goes into the wrong
direction I feel like um I feel like I
would be a person that's capable of
helping those people uh take the right
path um so that's my goal and I need 5.7
million euros to be able to provide for
me and my girlfriend and a couple of
kids uh and and lead the life that we
would want to have so so that's what I'm
working towards um and I'd like to
achieve that when uh I'm 40 which means
I have six and a half years to go
um I I I like touching upon the topic I
also dislike it partly because it makes
me sound like a saint on the other hand
I I haven't done it right like so I can
talk about it but right now I I haven't
done anything like that before um but I
would really like to do that at some
point um so I am quite focal about it
just to you know um well if you're
talking about that's what you want then
it's more likely to happen as well right
I agree I actually read somewhere
recently that said if you have goals
like you shouldn't share them someone
posted on LinkedIn I I think I was I
disagree with it so much yeah I I feel
like you just shared this with like
thousands of people so for me it's more
about by sharing these things it's you
you then even hold yourself more
accountable absolutely and there's
people that say like I've I've had
people that said to me oh you should
speak with this person they also became
a psychologist I've had those
conversations and that that made me more
aware what do I need to do in order to
get there so throughout my entire career
it has really helped being vocal about
my goal
uh so not planning on stopping anywhere
soon you you must be getting plenty of
practice working in and helping yeah
although yeah like I'm open with sharing
these numbers now speaking to a lot of
recruiters but obviously I wouldn't
quickly share that with um yeah the
company in terms of like recruitment is
difficult so like helping you know
people who are TW you know 20 30 uh
years old with the the highs and lows
that can often come with recruitment
mentally like I'm sure you're getting
some good practice in with that yeah
that's
true
absolutely um M it's been a pleasure
really you know love your approach love
your your mindset I think it's really
cool what you're what you're building
and like just continuing uh yeah going
to continue to be excited to to see how
it unravels so thanks so much for for
joining me on the Pod yeah likewise he
sham I think what your building is
really cool too so we'll stay in close
contact